you may receive endotracheal intubation
and mechanical ventilation if you are in
an emergency situation involving severe
respiratory problems or if you are
having general anesthesia during a
surgical procedure when you breathe air
moves into your lungs when a muscle
called the diaphragm along with other
muscles nearby contracts and causes the
chest cavity to expand air is exhaled
when these muscles relaxed and the lung
tissue passively returns to its original
size this is called respiration during
respiration oxygen in the air passes
through your nose or mouth and into your
pharynx or throat it then goes into your
trachea or windpipe your trachea divides
to become the left and right main
bronchi which enter your lungs inside
your lungs the main bronchi divide
repeatedly and eventually become small
tubes called bronchioles at the end of
the bronchioles are tiny air sacs called
alveoli oxygen in your alveoli is
absorbed into nearby blood vessels
called capillaries at the same time
carbon dioxide a gas in your blood that
must be removed passes into the alveoli
and back out through the airways this
process is called gas exchange if you
have severe respiratory problems the
oxygen levels in your blood may drop too
low or the carbon dioxide levels may
rise too high either of these conditions
can result in damage to your vital
organs including your heart and brain
some conditions that may lead to severe
respiratory problems include drowning
and obstruction in the trachea such as a
foreign object or tumor obstructive
pulmonary diseases such as asthma
chronic bronchitis and emphysema
diseases such as pneumonia and acute
respiratory distress syndrome or a RDS
severe weakness of the muscles that
control breathing and damage to the
bones and tissues of the chest under
these circumstances you may need
additional oxygen or breathing support
through mechanical ventilation
mechanical ventilation is also used
during surgical procedures for
delivering anesthetic drugs preventing
the aspiration of stomach contents into
the lungs and closely controlling the
levels of oxygen and carbon dioxide in
the blood during surgery before you are
intubated and ventilated for a surgical
procedure an intravenous line or IV will
be started and your doctor will give you
medication through your IV to put you to
sleep as the medication takes effect he
or she will place an oxygen mask over
your nose and mouth and ask you to
breathe deeply ensuring that you will
have a reserve of oxygen in your system
prior to the procedure the first step in
mechanical ventilation is called
endotracheal intubation once you're
asleep your doctor will use an
instrument called a laryngoscope to
perform the intubation a laryngoscope
which consists of a handle lights and
dull blade helps guide the endotracheal
tube to its proper position your doctor
will tilt your head back slightly and
insert the laryngoscope through your
mouth and down into your throat taking
special care to avoid contact with your
teeth
using the blade your doctor will gently
raise the epiglottis which is a flap of
tissue protecting your larynx he or she
will then advance the tip of the
endotracheal tube into the trachea
once the endotracheal tube is in the
trachea your doctor will inflate a small
balloon surrounding the tube to make
sure it remains snugly in place your
doctor will remove the laryngoscope and
tape the tube to the corner of your
mouth to prevent it from being jostled
out of position your doctor will check
to see that the tube is properly
positioned in the lower part of the
trachea by inflating your lungs with a
special bag and listening for breath
sounds on both sides of your chest if
the end of the tube is too low both
lungs will not receive the same amount
of air in some cases an x-ray is taken
immediately after intubation to confirm
the tubes placement once the
endotracheal tube is in the proper
position your doctor will attach it to
the mechanical ventilator a specially
designed pump that aids respiration by
delivering well oxygenated air into the
lungs and permitting carbon dioxide to
escape from the lungs levels of oxygen
and carbon dioxide will be closely
monitored to confirm that the ventilator
is working once your surgical procedure
is complete your doctor will not remove
the endotracheal tube until you were
able to safely breathe on your own he or
she will make this determination by
measuring how often you take a breath
and how much air you breathe in and out
with each breath